[Música]
[Aplausos]
vamos a imaginar por un momento qué
pasaría si el día de hoy en nuestra
actualidad no pudiéramos hacer uso de
los teléfonos celulares de las
computadoras y de un sinfín de
tecnología que tenemos ahora a la mano
y vamos a hacernos la siguiente pregunta
podríamos vivir sin esta tecnología
actualmente
para responder esta y otras preguntas
vamos a transportarnos en el tiempo
cuando muchos de nosotros éramos niños
cuando veíamos de repente las
caricaturas las películas series de
ciencia ficción y nos emocionaba y nos
motivaba a saber las posibilidades del
viaje en el espacio de los robots de las
máquinas pensantes
en todo ello precisamente
una próxima frontera de la humanidad
nació en esa época que al día de hoy
estamos viviendo a qué me refiero la
conquista del espacio hemos sabido que
aproximadamente en el año 2030 la
humanidad estaremos conquistando marte
y muchos viajes incluso de seres humanos
sin retorno para tener colonias humanas
en marte esto es obviamente algo muy
positivo porque porque el ser humano
estamos avanzando en todos los aspectos
sin embargo hasta qué punto estamos
identificando
que la tecnología hace un medio y no un
fin
tal vez a muchos de nosotros nos ha
sucedido que llegamos a nuestra clase
llegamos a entrega algún trabajo en una
memoria usb decimos ahí traigo mis
archivos y de repente los checamos y ya
no tenemos absolutamente nada a qué se
debe esto a lo que todos conocemos como
un virus un virus informático cuál es la
idea cuál es el concepto de un virus es
en la biología un organismo que puede
hacer daño en la tecnología es
igualmente pero quienes han diseñado
estos virus los programadores si así es
pero con ideas muy diversas muy variadas
esto nos lleva a pensar precisamente
hasta qué punto estamos llegando
tecnológicamente hablando como humanidad
en la misma tecnología estamos teniendo
pasos agigantados tan solo hace 10 años
los teléfonos celulares lo recordamos
eran con botones ahora son táctiles
de 'smartphones'
pero como mismos seres humanos estamos
cayendo en un bache porque porque
nuestra esencia está decayendo en esto
hago el siguiente ejemplo cuántos de
nosotros no hemos visto por ahí las
imágenes que conocemos en internet
llamadas como memes que de repente hay
una familia que va a visitar a su
abuelita de la tercera edad ella
emocionada porque la van a visitar y de
repente su propia familia todos están en
su celular
hay otra imagen otro m por ahí donde hay
un concierto y está también la abuelita
se le dibuja una sonrisa en su cara de
la emoción pero todos en el momento
quieren grabar con su celular en vídeo o
en fotografía esto nos lleva a
reflexionar hasta qué punto estamos
llegando como humanidad
el reciente el recientemente fallecido
físico stephen hawking
en una entrevista que se realizó hace
algunos años de que opinaba de que si
estaba de acuerdo en que la humanidad a
través de proyectos como el set y la
búsqueda inteligencia extraterrestre
inteligente con base en agresivo en
puerto rico
y estuviera de una manera sumamente
insistente buscando señales del universo
y se le pregunto steffen la humanidad
estamos preparados para el hipotético
contacto con inteligencias
extraterrestres
stephen hawking respondió consideró que
no porque porque nuestro propio planeta
es cierto la tecnología estamos
avanzando a pasos agigantados pero que
estamos creando nosotros mismos guerras
del hombre contra el hombre más allá de
la hambruna que estamos sufriendo en
nuestro propio planeta y de muchos otros
aspectos de toda índole y él mismo
comentó una hipótesis sumamente
interesante
dijo lo siguiente consideró que en el
caso de que se pudiera conseguir un
contacto con una hipotética civilización
extraterrestre no sería con una
civilización inteligente de tipo
orgánica el periodista en cuestión le
pregunta a qué se refiere lo que pasa
que muy posiblemente la mayoría la gran
mayoría de las posibles civilizaciones
extraterrestres que pudieran existir
sean las inteligencias artificiales que
pudieron crear estas civilizaciones que
de alguna manera no tuvieron control
sobre ellas mismas y se revelaron hace
tan solo también algunos meses algunas
empresas de tecnología mundial
mencionaron lo siguiente
que a partir del año 2045 iba a ser una
realidad que si alguien muere
transportar su conciencia humana
a un androide a una máquina esto nos
lleva a pensar también muchas
reflexiones
repito e insisto hasta qué punto estamos
llegando como humanidad en esa evolución
si utilizamos a favor la misma
tecnología obviamente es una maravilla
para todos nosotros estas conferencias
que se están grabando y que estarán
gravadas ahora así que para la eternidad
es en base a esa tecnología
el medio de comunicación como son las
redes sociales si lo usamos a nuestro
favor también es una gran maravilla pero
también depende el uso y la forma
en la década de los 40 s el biólogo
isaac asimov
y también un prolífico autor de ciencia
ficción instauró las tres leyes de la
robótica cuáles son la primera ley dice
así un robot jamás deberá hacerle daño a
un ser humano la segunda ley
un robot siempre debe de proteger al ser
humano siempre y cuando no afecte
la primer ley y la tercera ley un robot
siempre se protegerá a sí mismo y a
otros robots siempre y cuando esto no
afecte con la primer ley
en su momento fue ciencia ficción en la
actualidad ya es una realidad e incluso
lo marca la legislación internacional en
robótica
cabe hacer mención nuestro país méxico
somos potencia mundial en robótica
siempre en los concursos y en torneos
internacionales de robótica con las
universidades de todo el mundo
afortunadamente nuestro país lleva entre
el primer y el segundo lugar sin embargo
dejó esta pregunta al aire en qué primer
lugar estamos en crear robots de pelea
esto nos lleva a la reflexión también
porque no
en otras instancias participar si hay
ese talento es esa capacidad de ese
conocimiento mexicano
participar cuando agencias
internacionales espaciales han convocado
a desarrollar robótica por ejemplo para
la sonda mars global surveyor que hace
algunos años empezó a explorar marte y
que afortunadamente se hizo fue un
equipo multidisciplinario de varias
universidades mexicanas que muchos
aspectos de esta sonda fueron creadas
por manos mexicanas pero ahí está
la clave entonces esto quiere decir este
frenado que intenta razón
que se puede repetir lo que pasa con ese
choque intercultural ese choque de
culturas como cuando cristóbal colón
conquistó américa que alguna hipotética
civilización extraterrestre
sea una inteligencia artificial que no
tenga una conciencia orgánica y por ende
una emoción como la podemos tener y
debemos tener todos los seres humanos
en ello
muchos de nosotros recordaremos
una película de la década de los 90s
de ficción también pero que ha de ser
mención la misma ficción a veces llega a
ser la motivación y la inspiración para
las en la ciencia real
en esta película que les decía
recordamos al personaje muchos sabrán a
quién me refiero
y hasta a punto de sacrificarse por los
seres humanos y les dice
ahora sé por qué lloran
esto nos lleva repito a replantearnos
muchas cuestiones humanamente hablando
también en base a todo esto en su
momento al gran científico del siglo 20
albert eisntein le preguntaron lo
siguiente
profesor
cómo considera usted de existir una
tercera guerra mundial que sería el
contexto
no lo sé no sé cómo sería una tercera
guerra mundial sin embargo de lo que sí
estoy total y completamente seguro es
que de haber una cuarta una cuarta
guerra mundial sería con palos y piedras
porque mejor no encauzar no dirigir esos
conocimientos tecnológicos
el futuro cercano que puede ser por
ejemplo con prótesis biónicas tal vez
muchos de nosotros vimos en películas
recientes que todavía están por ahí en
cartelera donde algunos personajes
superhéroes de ciencia ficción pierden
un brazo pero en una pierna y les
implantan un brazo una pierna biónica
esto en la actualidad ya está empezando
a ser posible porque también no
desarrollamos aún más la tecnología y la
hacemos más accesible para todos
nosotros cuando alguna persona tiene
alguna enfermedad que no pueda caminar
por ejemplo para eso ya se están
desarrollando los exoesqueletos que en
base a ello apoyándonos en este tipo de
tecnología estas personas pueden volver
a caminar
porque repito la pregunta no en causamos
más positivamente
esos conocimientos a esta tecnología a
nuestro favor y no hacerlo a un fin como
desafortunadamente tal vez de manera
inconsciente muchos de nosotros lo
estamos haciendo sino conscientemente
volverla a un medio a nuestro favor y
aunque el mismo albert einsten mencionó
esto prácticamente en la época de la
segunda guerra mundial
unas décadas después un gran pensador y
motivador a nivel mundial como lo fue
martin luther king' mencionó lo
siguiente
si yo supiera que el mundo se acaba
mañana yo aún el día de hoy plantaría un
árbol que esto nos lleve muchísimo a la
motivación de que la tecnología es
excelente para todos nosotros siempre y
cuando sea un medio muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]